hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now extreme downpours could
become four times more frequent in 50
years time if greenhouse gas emissions
remain high that's according to a new
study from the Met Office which found
that for every degree of warming the
intensity of extreme downpours could
also increase by up to 15 percent in
England alone an estimated 3 million
properties are at risk from surface
water flooding well let's speak now to
the lead author of that report Professor
Lizzie Kendon who is a climate scientist
at the Met Office Lizzy thank you so
much for talking to us so what did you
find
so we we here we're running some very
high resolution climate simulations so
we're using the the model that we
typically use for operational weather
forecasting here at the Met Office but
we're now using it to look at how
climate might emerge over the coming
years and decades right out to the end
of the century under a high emission
scenario and what we found is that um
extreme rainfall events um the type of
events that can lead to flash flooding
um are going to increase four times in
by 2080 compared to 1980s if we follow a
higher emission scenario
so the sort of event I'm talking about
here is like the sort of event we had in
London um back in July 2021 when Kew
Gardens Got A month's rainfall in about
three hours and that led to real big
disruption so we had
um you know tube stations closed
um and lots of lots of flooding in
London and then actually a couple of
weeks later we had a very similar event
which led to two hospitals being flooded
in London so these are the sort of
events we're talking about here they can
lead to really a major disruption and if
we follow a high emission scenario we're
seeing really big increases in these
sort of events in the future
um and I think it's important to say
that these this these results this four
times increase
is
um is for high emissions scenario so the
changes aren't inevitable and they're
very much conditioned on the future
scenario we follow and if we if we emit
less then the changes will be less but I
think whatever future scenario we follow
with we're expecting big changes in
heavy rainfall extremes because you know
for every single degree of regional
warming we're talking about a five to
fifteen percent increase in the
intensity of these downpours just
briefly if we've had the driest summer
we've had for 30 years and the driest
February we've had for 30 years it
doesn't really seem consistent with your
findings though
so actually we do expect Summers to get
drier and these projections are very
much consistent with that so that
there's an overall drying picture in
summer because of climate change but the
rainfall will come in the form of much
intense downpours when it does happen so
there'll be you know more of these
intense downpours and then drier periods
in between but I think what's really
important about these projections that
we're issuing now is they allow us to
look at an envelope of climate as we
move through time year by year so it's
not just a single projection there are a
number of different realizations and
what we can see is that exactly how you
know climate change will materialize on
a year by year basis is far from a
smooth steady Trend so we may still get
you know very wet Summers even though
the overall drying picture it you know
is is the underlying Trend and actually
um what these results show is is we can
actually get also some quite rapid
transitions in our climate so we might
have lots and lots of years with
relative the few of these extreme
downpours and then suddenly we can have
a jump in the climate when we appear to
have a lot more of these events
um and you know and a considerable
increase in record-breaking events
compared to what we've observed up to
that point and that's purely just
direction of the interplay between
um natural variability in the climate
and the underlying Trend and due to
human greenhouse gas emissions okay
Lizzy thank you so much for talking to
us
foreign
making the news now and more than half
of Britain and Ireland's native plants
have declined since the 1950s because of
issues like intensive farming and
climate change warmer weather means some
species like the bee Orchid have spread
North but the change has forced back
increasingly rare Mountain plants like
snow Pearl water which can only be found
on the Snowy Peaks of Ben lauers in the
Scottish Highlands Britain is one of the
most nature depleted countries in the
world
more than a dozen major cities in China
have seen temperatures hit record
seasonal highs Central cities like Wuhan
and genju recorded temperatures of 26
degrees Celsius that's more than 10
degrees higher than normal for early
March the country's weather bureau has
warned that China faces another year of
extreme weather as a result of global
climate change
Britain Drew on reserve coal power
plants for the first time this winter as
a cold snap grips the UK the National
Grid has placed the plants on standby a
number of times but this is the first
time they've been needed to feed
electricity to the grid the coal plants
were due to close last September as the
UK transitions away from fossil fuels
with the UK's demand for coal at its
lowest level since 1757.
new research shows plastic entering
oceans could nearly triple by 2040 if
left unchecked a new study by the Five
jazz Institute which is an organization
that campaigns to reduce pollution in
the sea says plastic in the oceans has
surged by an unprecedented amount well
let's speak now to the ocean campaign
leader at the environmental
investigation agency Christina Dixon
there she is hello to you to Christina
so how is it hi that we have seen a
surge of Plastics in our oceans when
there is seemingly such awareness about
the danger of plastics
well unfortunately you know while
awareness has been growing in recent
years and we've seen a huge uptick in in
people recognizing this is a problem and
wanting to do something about it the
reality is that the growth of plastic in
the environment so as this study shows
in the oceans has also grown in tandem
with plastic production so we've seen
absolutely no decline in the amount of
plastic being produced in fact
projections show that plastic is going
to continue to increase so if we keep
producing plastic unfortunately we will
keep seeing plastic in the environment
and that's that's the facts so are we
not doing enough then
currently we are not doing enough at the
moment we have really a patchwork of
voluntary commitments from companies
that are invariably missed um and
legislation around the world that is
fragmented at best so really what we
need to see is a global legally binding
instrument that can address the full
life cycle of plastics so something that
can deal with the production of plastics
through the whole life cycle to the
point of disposal or you know cleaning
up in the environment although we really
don't want to focus on cleanups we want
to focus on turning off the problem at
source so the really good news is and I
like I like having some good news to
share with you the um governments around
the world have agreed to negotiate a
Plastics treaty and at the moment we're
sort of part way through the development
of that treaty so by the end of 2024
that treaty should be agreed hopefully
is that the UN proposed treaty that
you're talking about that was on last
year I think in Nairobi
exactly so last year in Nairobi
governments agreed to the mandate to
negotiate a new Plastics treaty so what
that basically did was kind of trigger
the start of negotiations so the
negotiations are a two-year process so
at this point we're in the phase where
governments are really agreeing what's
the scope of the treaty going to be you
know how far Upstream should it begin
should it begin at for example you know
ending harmful subsidies that promote
fossil fuel expansion for example or
should it start more at the point of
plastic production polymerization should
it deal with chemicals that kind of
thing and those are really the details
that are being fleshed out through a
series of negotiations that are taking
place this year and next year and so by
the end of 2024 we'll have the treaty
text and then that will be open for
adoption in 2025.
can we ever completely get rid of all
the Plastics that we have already dumped
into our oceans
though I think that um cleaning up
plastic that is already in the
environment is really complex and I
think this study in particular points to
the issue of microplastics so cleaning
microplastics is incredibly difficult
and whilst we can focus on Remediation
in areas where it's particularly
problematic you know I'm thinking about
for example in soils in fresh water in
the oceans
um you know we can do some cleanup but I
think the really critical element that I
would love you know people to take away
is that stopping the problem from
entering the environment in the first
place is really going to be the most
effective intervention so whilst you
know there is a role for remediation
it's really not the the sort of golden
ticket here okay Christina thank you so
much for talking to us
thanks
now before we go we want your climate
questions anything that has ever
mystified you about the environment or
whatever you want to get to the bottom
of scan this QR code and send us your
questions which we will answer in the
climate Show with Tom Heap
and you can watch Tom's show it's on
Saturday and Sunday at 3 30 in the
afternoon here on Sky News
thank you so much for watching that's
all from us today we'll see you tomorrow